snc-lavalin sera le maître d'oeuvre de
la portion américaine du projet
champlain hudson power express la ligne
de transport d'électricité par hydro
québec jusqu'à new york l'entreprise
montréalaise spécialisée en ingénierie
va travailler à concevoir des câbles
sous marins et souterrains à haute
tension la valeur du contrat n'est pas
dévoilée pour la portion sur le
territoire québécois qui s'étend sur 58
km c'est hydro-québec qui va chapeauter
les travaux la société d'état espère
pouvoir commencer dès le printemps 2023
avec nous ce soir pierre olivier pineau
titulaire de la chaire de gestion du
secteur de l'énergie à hec montréal
bonsoir mon sens et filion alors cette
annonce survient alors qu'hydro québec
vient tout juste de recevoir
l'approbation des autorités de l'état de
new york pour le projet qui doit
permettre de combler jusqu'à 20% des
besoins de new york parlez-nous de
l'importance historique de ce contrat
bien s'est il ya plusieurs aspects qui
font que c'est un contrat historique
premièrement c'est le plus gros contrat
que hydro-québec a signé avec un
partenaire américain et donc c'est
quelque chose mais surtout et je pense
que c'est au delà de la quantité
d'énergie du contrat c'est la ligne de
transmission qui va être bâti c'est la
première en plusieurs décennies que de
cette ampleur là on sait qu hydro québec
depuis longtemps cherche à exporter
davantage et avoir des lignes de
transport d'électricité vers les états
unis il ya eu plusieurs des bois avec le
new hampshire avec le maine et ça c'est
un projet qui va finalement être
construits et pour le long terme c'est
extrêmement important d'être mieux
interconnectés avec nos voisins tout le
monde va y gagner le québec et new york
à avoir une interconnexion de plus
quelle expertise de snc lavalin en
matière d'infrastructures
hydroélectriques
alors dans ce cas ci c'est pas vraiment
une infrastructure hydroélectrique parce
que c'est vraiment la ligne en cas
courant continu haute tension qui va
être construit donc snc-lavalin est
vraiment maître d'oeuvre dans cette
ligne là mais
c'est très lié à l'hydroélectricité mais
pas uniquement pour parcourir des
longues distances c'est important
d'avoir des lignards tension en courant
continu pour minimiser les pertes
d'énergie qui sont liées au transport de
l'électricité sur des longues distances
snc lavalin à des expertises dans de
multiples domaines mais a été le maître
d'oeuvre dans d'autres projets
similaires et plus récemment dans le bas
churchill ils ont construit la ligne
haute tension du projet - squatt force
et en alberta aussi ils ont fait une
ligne à haute tension et donc qu'ils ont
une expertise de récentes qui vont
pouvoir approfondir ici dans ce projet
là et ce qui est particulier c'est 545
km mais soumaré de câbles sous-marins de
câbles souterrains qu'est ce que ça
implique
alors c'est si l'une des spécificités de
ce projet là comme vous l'avez mentionné
c'est qu'on ne verra pas les lignes à
haute tension c'est un élément majeur
dans l'acceptabilité sociale du projet
dans le cadre du new hampshire et du
maine c'est ce qui avait fait dérailler
un l'acceptabilité des projets
s'impliquent qui est bien que c'est
déposer au fond du du lac champlain et
après ça va aller dans la rivière hudson
donc il faut s'assurer que les câbles
sont conçus pour résister au fond mais
au fond de l'eau c'est pas que ce n'est
pas quelque chose d'inédit dans les pays
européens construisent ce genre de
câbles par exemple danemark est
interconnecté avec la norvège avec la
suède et même le danemark
s'interconnecte avec l'angleterre avec
des câbles dans ce cas là sous marins
mais ici ça va être sous l'eau sous un
lac et une rivière quelque elles par des
surplus d'hydro-québec ce projet va-t-il
captée par ce qu'elle a de plus en plus
chez hydro-québec on ne parle plus de
surplus on affirme qu'il n'y a plus ou
qu'il n'y aura plus bientôt de surplus
alors c'est une bonne question parce que
la situation est un peu complexe et
n'est pas facile à décortiquer hydro
québec exporte ces dernières années
hydro québec a exporté 15 térawattheures
d'électricité vers new york et ce
contrat est un contrat de dix paires à
water donc dans les faits hydro québec
pourrait ne pas exporter davantage
d'électricité à new york ce qu'elle fait
déjà la différence c'est que c'est un
contrat ferme sur 25 ans qui l'obligent
à exporter à un bon prix tandis que ces
exportations ces dernières années
c'était des comptes s'était heure par
heure et elle pouvait cesser à tout
moment elle n'avait pas d'engagement à
long terme les surplus d'hydro-québec
sont évalués autour de 30 térawattheures
en 2019 c'était au tour de 30
térawattheures qui incluait dont
beaucoup d'exportation déjà
mais s'il y aura il y aura
éventuellement une concurrence avec les
besoins croissants du québec mais comme
hydro québec s'est engagé à exporter et
bien s'il ya des besoins croissants il
va falloir construire des nouvelles
installations de production au québec
donc des éoliennes ça fait partie de ce
qui vient d'être annoncé par le québec
oui absolument non seulement hydro
québec a annoncé là par une première
participation dans des parcs éoliens
avec énergie et boralex mais le
gouvernement québécois a annoncé des
appels d'offres qui allait venir de plus
de mémoire ces 3 ou 4000 mégawatts
supplémentaires d'appels d'offres cinq
mille 5000 et 3000 pour l'éolien
voilà ce qui est un petit peu paradoxal
parce que c'est le gouvernement qui
l'annoncent mais c'est hydro québec qui
a ses plans d'approvisionnement et qui
doit faire la prévision de la demande
donc on a un petit peu d'ingérence
politique avec un gouvernement qui
annonce des appels d'offres qui devrait
relever d'hydro-québec et par la suite
d'être approuvé par la régie de
l'énergie mais il y aurait à dire sur la
manière dont on planifie les besoins
énergétiques du québec ben dis donc
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on doit
comprendre de cette planification
c'est qu'elle est elle est floue on sait
que pour la transition énergétique on a
besoin de beaucoup d'énergie hydro
québec dans son plan stratégique par de
100 térawattheures en plus d'ici à 2050
mais on ne sait pas encore comment
est-ce que ça va être
satisfaits comme demandé production
supplémentaire donc ça serait bien
d'avoir un plan de match qui nous
permettent de savoir justement où on 120
quels sont ses besoins à combler est ce
qu'on a vraiment besoin de combler ses
besoins ce que ça va être pour
l'électrification du transport est ce
que ça va être pour des nouvelles
industries est-ce que ça va être pour
l'exportation il ya un flou artistique
qui est un peu maintenue on n'a pas de
plan clair r sur comment on va générer
toute cette électricité là pour quels
besoins exacts et donc il serait
important pour que les québécois sachent
où on s'en va que ça soit clarifiée dans
les années à venir ce sont des questions
fondamentales merci beaucoup pierre
olivier pineau d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir ça m'a fait plaisir merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit